now we would be having the question and
answer
session to derive more benefit for all
of those present here in the limited
time that we have available we would
like the following rules to be
observed your questions asked should be
on the topic of the day Quran and modern
science conflict or conciliation
only questions not relevant to the topic
will not be
entertained kindly State your questions
briefly and to the point this is
question answer time and not lecture
time only one question at a time will be
permitted for your second question you
would have to go behind the row and
await your second chance
we have three mics provided on the
ground two on my sides right side one
left side one these are for the gents
and we have one behind in the center in
the ladies section for the ladies I told
there are people watching this
program in the alma latifi Hall which is
full on the video screen I would request
those
Brothers if they have any questions to
kindly come down in the ground the
volunteers present at your end would
assist you in
it we will allow only one question on
each of the mics in clockwise rotation
first the ladies second the Gent on my
right third the Gent on my left and so
on in clockwise
manner written questions on papers or
slips which are available from our
Volunteers in the
aisles would be given secondary
preference after the open questions on
the mics are answered by Dr
Zakir in the interest of having a less
time wasting a more educative and an
interesting question and answer session
our decision to allow or disallow
irrelevant questions will be
final in the interest of eliciting a
proper and clear answer from the speaker
kindly state your name and profession
before putting forward your question so
his answer can be more appropriate to
your
understanding may we have the first
question from the ladies
section assalam alikum I am CER shik a
product of Dar Quran Kuwait presently
I'm teaching Arabic in anushakti nagar
my question is it is mentioned in the
Quran that one day in the site of Allah
is equal to a th000 years and in another
place it is mentioned that one day is
equal to 50,000 years isn't the Quran
cont contradicting itself please
explain the sister asked a question that
it's mentioned in the Quran in certain
place that one day in the sight of Allah
is equal to a th years and somewh else
has mentioned that one day in the sight
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala is equal to
50,000 years isn't this a contradiction
what the sister was referring to is a
verse of the Holy Quran from Surah alhaj
chter 22 verse number 47 as well as
Surah s 32 verse number five which does
say that one day in the sight of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala is equal to th000
years and in Sur Mar chapter 17 verse
number four it says that one day in the
sight of Allah subhana wa taala is equal
to a 50,000 years of your Reckoning
doesn't it seem to be a contradiction
sister what these verses in the Holy
Quran referring to it's giving you an
indication that time in the sight of
Allah wa tala is incomparable to the
Earthly
time the Earthly time whether it's a
thousand years or whether it's 50,000
years or whether thousands of years it's
somewhat equal to one day in the sight
of Allah or maybe one second in the
sight of Allah subhana tala it's just
giving you a reference that time in the
sight of Allah subhana wa ta'ala is
incomparable to the Earthly time but
even if you want to take these verses
literally still there's an explanation
for for
that the Arabic word used in this verses
is y it has got two different meanings
it can either be translated as day or as
period or as Epoch very long period so
if you read this verse of Sur sa chapter
32 verse number five it says it is Allah
who rules the
affairs from the Heavens to the Earth
and all these go up to him on a day
which is equal to a thousand years of
Reckoning if you translate the word
correctly y as period it will read that
Allah rules all the affairs from the
Heavens to the Earth and all of them go
unto him in a period which is equal to a
thousand year of your Reckoning Sur
marah 17 verse number four reads
that the spirits and the angels they
ascend unto Allah subhana wa ta'ala in a
day which is equal to 50,000 years of
your Reckoning if you translate it
correctly y as period it will read that
the spirits and the angels Ascend unto
Allah subhana wa ta'ala in a period
equal to 50,000
years the Quran is referring to two
different periods therefore there's no
contradiction for example if I say I
will take one hour to reach Washi I will
take a period of one hour to reach Washi
and then say I will take a period of 50
hours to reach Shri nagar to reach
Kashmir it's not contradicting because
both are different periods so one place
Quran says the period required
for all the spirits and the angels to go
up unto Allah subhana wa ta'ala is equal
to 50,000 years of your Reckoning and
the other placees the period required
for all the Affairs to go into Allah
subhana wa ta'ala is 1,000 years there's
no contad in that I hope to answer the
question salum Zakir my name is Shakir
and I'm a mechanical engineer student I
would like to ask your a question that
uh how can you prove to an atheist
scientifically the existence of
God the brother POS the question how can
you scientifically prove the existence
of God almighty Mighty the existence of
Allah subhana wa
taala to especially to an
atheist who does not believe in
God the first thing I will do is that I
will congratulate that atheist I
congratulate him you know why if you
look around us he's a Hindu because
father is a Hindu he's a Christian
because father is a Christian some
Muslims are Muslims because their
fathers are Muslim this person though he
may be coming from religion background
he does not believe in the false god
which is parents attribute to so he does
not believe in God I'm congratulating
him because he's accepted the first part
of the shahada the first part of the
Islamic
Creed there is no God now my job is to
prove ill but Allah which I shall do
inshallah to the other people I have to
first remove the wrong concept of God
and then prove the right concept of
Allah subhana wa tala here half my job
is done he has already
said there's no God now I have to prove
but Allah which I shall do
inshallah you ask this atheist that
Suppose there is an object an
unidentified maybe a flying object which
no one in the world has seen no human
being in the world knows about his
object if it's brought in front of you
and if you asked
that who will be the first person who
will be able to tell you the mechanism
of this unidentified object you have to
ask him the question who is the first
person who will be able to tell you the
mechanism of this new object which no
one in the world has
seen after thinking for a while he'll
give the answer the person who will be
able to tell you the mechanism the first
person is the creator of that
object some may say manufacturer
somebody say producer whatever they say
don't grapple with the word accept it it
will be somewhat similar either Creator
or producer or manufacturer but remember
what he has told you keep it in your
mind then ask him the next question how
did the universe come into existence how
was it form he will tell you by The Big
Bang Theory tell him the Quran mentions
in Surah Amia 21 verse number 30 about
the Big Bang Theory who could have
mentioned this in the qu
400 years ago so he will tell you maybe
it's a Flo don't argue with him next
part of the question we did not know the
light of the moon is reflected light we
came to know
recently you ask him you tell yes yes
the light of the moon is reflected light
it's not its own light when we
discovered he will tell you recently
yesterday 50 years back 100 years back
yesterday in fans you tell him the Quran
mentions that the light of the moon is
reflected light 1,400 years ago who
could have mentioned that maybe somebody
had a wild guess don't argue with him
continue we thought the sun was
stationary you ask him is it stationary
you said no it's rotating and
revolving when you learn this he will
tell you yesterday 50 years back 100
years back Quran mentions this 1400
years ago he will hesitate but may say
maybe some intelligent person rooted
don't argue with him
continue how was the universe initially
what isal matter he will tell you it was
Smoke how did you come to know we have
got proof we have got evidence you tell
him Quran mentioned this 14 years ago
who could have mentioned that he will
hesitate don't wait for response
continue keep on posing question after
question wall that I given the lecture
keep on posing one question after the
other that water cycle how do we come to
know about it Quran mentioned 400 years
ago about every living thing made from
water who could have mention that Quran
speaks about botney the male and female
who could have mentioned that PA one
after the other and ask the question who
could have written
that then you tell him that there's a
theory known as theory of
probability that if you have two Choice
out of which one is right the chances
that you will make the correct
choice just at random is one and two for
example if I toss a coin it can either
be heads or tails the chances that I'll
be right will be one and two if I toss
it twice the chances that I'll be right
both the times will be 1 upon 2 multip 1
upon 2 that is 1 upon 4 25%
chance if I toss it Thrice chances I'll
be right all three times one upon two
Monday 1 upon 2 multi 1 upon 2 it's 1
upon 8
122% a dice has got six sides if I throw
a dice the chances that at random I'll
be correct is 1 upon six if I throw it
twice the chances that both the time
I'll be right will be 1 upon 6 by 1 upon
6 1 upon
36 this is called as theory of
probability if I throw the dice twice
and then toss a coin all three being
right will be 1 upon 6 by 1 upon 6 by 1
upon 2 is 1 upon
72 so you ask him the chances maybe if
you ask what is the shape of the
earth there are various shapes some may
say it is flat some may say it's
triangular some may say it is hexagonal
some may say pentagonal some may say
heptagonal some may say Square say they
can be 10
shapes some may say it is round it is
spherical the chances that if anyone
makes a wild guess it being correct is 1
upon
10 the light of the Moon it can either
be its own light or it can be reflected
light the chances that you make a wild
guess and it being correct will be one
upon two the chances that both shape of
the earth and light of the Moon being
reflected light both being correct if
you make a v guess it will be 1 upon 10
multip 1 upon 2 it is 1 upon 20
what can the living creatures be made of
some may say sand some may say Stone
some may say aluminium some may say gold
say a thousand materials you can name
some may say water some may say silver a
thousand material the chances that you
make a wild guess and one of them being
right according to mathematics is one
upon a thousand the chances that all
three being correct the Earth is
spherical light of the moon is reflected
light and every living creature create
from water is correct will be 1 upon 10
multip 1 upon 2 multip by 1 upon th000
answer comes to 1 upon 20,000 or
05% Quran speaks about scientific signs
more than a thousand verses in three
verses the chance comes to
05% if you apply probability Theory to
all this being at random chance it will
come to zero negligible and in math
anything one in 10 ra to 50 it's equal
to zero so you ask your atheist friend
who could have written this the only
answer he can give you is his first
answer the Creator the
manufacturer the person who has produced
it that's the only answer there's no
other answer what science is saying
today is they are not eliminating God
they are eliminating models of
God illah they are not eliminating God
but models of God I hope the answer the
question uh my name is Javid and I'm a
student I would like to ask a
question at one place the Holy Quran
states that man is Created from
spum which is in consolate with modern
science but at another place it also
states that man is made from dust
Now isn't the Holy Quran contradicting
itself or is it consolate with modern
science the Brother P the
question that one place the Holy Quran
says that human beings have been created
from sperm which conat with modern
science they are the place human being
is cre from dust can you prove it
scientifically SC from dust and isn't
their contradiction one place SPM one
place it says
dust the Holy Quran does say as I
mentioned my
talk
in 75 verse number 37 to39 it says that
human beings have been created from
sperm which has been
proved by
science the Holy Quran also says in
Surah Haj 22 verse number five that we
have created the human beings from a
quintessence of
dust today science tells us that all the
elements that are there in the human
body they are present in lesser or
greater quantity in the soil in the
earth so the statement that human being
have been created from Earth is
scientifically proven that whatever
components are there in the human body
the constituent the elements they
present in the earth in the soil in
lesser or greater
proportion the second part of the
question isn't a contradiction one place
the Quran says man is Created from sperm
one saves from dust is it in
contradiction see a
contradiction is two statements which
are conflicting with each
other which cannot take place
simultaneously the Quran does not only
say man has been created from sperm and
the other place from dust It also says
in Surah fan 25: 54 that man has been
created from water you will tell me that
three contradictions
see science has proven that man has been
created from dust as well as from sperm
as well as from water if I tell you in
one statement that to make a cup of tea
I require water in the second statement
I say to make a cup of
tea I require tea leaves or tea powder
it's not a contradiction I require both
if I want to make sweet tea I add sugar
to it if I want to make p some tea I add
less water and more milk if I want to
make sumani tea I add only
water so there is no contradiction when
the Quran says human being is Created
from
sperm and dust and water it is actually
Contra
distinction what is the meaning of
Contra distinction Contra distinction
means speaking two or more things about
a subject which are not conflicting with
each other
for example if I say that this man he's
honest he's kind and
loving it is contradistinction but if I
say this man is always a liar and a
truthful person then it's contradiction
because both are opposing if it's not
opposing it's called as counter
[Applause]
distinction next question question from
the ladies
section asalam alikum brother my name is
farida Ansari I am a laboratory
technician Quran says Allah is the
creator of the human being does science
agree with
it the sister POS a question that the
Quran mentions that Allah subhana wa
ta'ala is the creator of the human
beings thus science agree with it and
Quran says in several places including
the last verse of theological stages
that is suron 23 verse number 14 that
Allah is the best to
create can we prove it
scientifically that Allah is the creator
Quran gives the answer Quran gives the
answer in Surah chapter 52 verse number
35 it poses a
question that were you created from
nothing see the Arabic word used for
Creator in all the vers of the Quran is
it derive from the Arabic
word Arabic word kalaka has got four
meanings one meaning is to create
something from nothing without any
previous example that's only possible
for Allah subhana tala second meaning of
kalaka is to create something new from
pre-existing
material the third meaning is of kalak
programming or planning and the last
meaning is to make smooth so Quran poses
a question in Surah chapter 52 verse 35
that were you created from nothing but
naturally the answer is negative no
human beings aren't created from nothing
they P the next
question were you the
creators or we the
creators we know very well that man
cannot create another man if you could
do that in the moment he died he would
have cre himself back if his relativ
would have died he would have brought
them back to life human beings can't
even create a living creature such as
fly Li side human
being neither can you attribute the
organs of the body say the reproductive
organs like testes or ovaries that they
are the cause for a creation but if you
say that the testes the utess ETC are
the cause then you have to include your
ancestors their reproductive system
their ancestors their ancestors
all are responsible so the answer is
negative Quran P the next question in
Sur chapter
56 verse number 58 and 59 that do you
not look at the sperm you have
emitted were you the Creator or we the
Creator and but n all these questions
that Quran poses the answer is negative
some people can say it's by chance
by chance you were created they a nature
nature natural thing it happened by
chance let's analyze scientifically
whether the human beings can be created
by
Chance the protein molecule is a very
important
structure of the living cell very
important part in the living structure
of the
cell the protein molecule consists of
five elements the carbon nitrogen oxygen
Hydro
and
sulfur and there are tens and thousands
of
atoms required to make one molecule one
atom has five elements carbon nitrogen
oxygen hydrogen and sulfur that tens of
thousands of atoms which make one
protein molecule and there are
approximately
92 free
elements the chances that out of these
92 the five will form an atom and these
atom will form tens and thousands of
atom to form one protein molecule was
calculated by Frank alien and he said
the chances are 1 in 10 raed to 160 you
know what is the meaning of 1 in 10 ra
to6 if I say 1 in 10 to two 10 to two
means 1 0 0 two zeros one in 100 chances
is 1% if I say 1 in 10 to 3 it means 1
in a,
that's. 1% if I say 1 in 10 to 4 it
means 1 in
10,000 means %. so when the calculation
was made 1 in 10 to 160 it means
0000 157 Zer then
one and Mathematics tells anything one
in ra to 10 ra to 50 it's counted as
zero furthermore this is talking about
one molecule and the substance
required to form this one molecule of
protein was calculated by another person
Charles
guy that it will require millions of
times of substance as us as our galaxies
millions of Galaxy will require to form
this one molecule of protein and the
time was calculated by Charles guy the
time taken for one protein molecule to
be formed will be 10 ra to 200 63 years
you know what is that 1
00 263 zos it will take to form one
protein
molecule and do you know there are how
many protein molecule in one
cell and do you know how many other
molecules are there in the cell and how
many cells are there in the human
being there are more than 6 billion
molecules when a child is born that's
for doctors tell us today 6
billion one protein molecule takes one
in 10 days to 160 chances time taken is
10 days to 263 years to take 6 billion
for one baby imagine and how many women
are pregnant there are millions of women
pregnant at a time and it takes only 9
months the chances science tells us is
00 0 no chance at
all these thing cannot take by chance
they have to be programmed by someone
sence tells us there has to be
someone some Supernatural Force
therefore science as I said earlier is
not eliminating God it is eliminating
models of
God hope the answer the
[Applause]
question salum my name is ashak and I'm
a student my question is Quran in
several places has mentioned men that
the heavens and the Earth were created
in 6 days but in Surah filat it says the
Heaven and the Earth was created in 8
days isn't this a
contradiction and the same verse also
says that the Earth was created in 6
days and then later on the heaven in 2
days this is against the big bang theory
that the heavens and earth were created
simultaneously
POS a very important
question the Quran says the heavens and
the Earth were created in six days when
Sur it says eight days is in their
contradiction and also contradiction
with the Big Bang Theory I do agree with
you brother the Quran says in several
places that the heavens and the Earths
were created six in several places in
Surah 7 verse number 54 in Surah yunus
10 verse number 3 in Surah HUD CH 11
verse number 7 in Sur furan 25 ver
number 59 in Sur SDA 32 ver number 4
in Sur Hadid 57 verse number four in
several places the Quran says the
heavens and the Earth were created in
six days it's not the Earthly days it is
aams very long periods which scientists
have got no objection to and I also
agree with you that the Quran does speak
about the creation of the Heaven and the
Earth in Sur fat the verse you referring
to brother is verses 9 to 12 which
says that
do you not believe in the one who has
created the Earth in two days and do you
join equals with him do you join
partners with him who's the lord of the
world verse number 10 says he has set on
the earth Mountain standing
firm and given due nourishment on the
earth in 4
days verse number 11 says moreover in
his design he comprehended the sky when
it was smoke and he said to it and the
Earth come me together willingly or
unwillingly and they said we come
together in willing
obedience this he did in two days so if
you read it just without thinking 2 + 4
+ 2 is 8
Days Quran gives the answer in the
starting of the verse that it says that
all those who will take out this
fault they are equal to those people who
will join Partners to God mean Allah
subh knew that there will be people who
will take out fault in the Quran in this
verse they will be the mushrik and today
this verse is commonly used by the
Christian missionaries against the
Muslims if you go around I've been
traveling the world this question was
supposed to me even there the Christian
missionaries they POS this
question Quran says it predicts that
people will ask about this question and
these people will be those who associate
partners with God
let's analyze the
first two verses that is Sur F chter 41
verse 9 and 10 says that the Earth was
created in 2 days and then mountains
were set on it and nourishment was given
in due proportion in 4 days so it says
two days the earth was formed mountains
was set on it afterwards in 4 days total
comes to 6 days then verse number 11
starts with the Arabic
word now the Arabic
word can be translated in three
different ways one is then one is
moreover and the other is
simultaneously I do know that many
translations have translated the Arabic
word thma as then if you translate Suma
as then then there is a
contradiction it says then the heavens
were made in two days that means 2+ 4
plus is equal to 8 days but the exact
translation should be Suma should be
translated as moreover or simultaneously
and abdah alhamdulillah in this place
has translated Suma correctly as
moreover so if you translate Summa as
moreover or simultaneously it will mean
that when the earth and the mountains
were created in 6 days simultaneously
the heavens were created in two days for
example suppose a builder he gives in
his
brochure that I have constructed a
10-story building along with its
surrounding and compound wall in 6
months when a person wants to buy a flat
in that building he goes to the Builder
and and he ask for more detail the
Builder says it took me 2 months to make
the basement of the building and another
4 months to make the 10 story and while
I was building the basement and the
story I simultaneously buil the compound
wall and the surrounding in 2 months
it's possible so then he's not
contradicting total comes to yes 6
months so similarly when Sur f chapter
41 verse number 9 to2 it says that while
the Earth was created along with the
mountain in 6 days simultaneously the
heavens was created in two days there's
no
contradiction and similarly if you take
then it contct with SS because Earth was
created first men were created the
mountains it's contradicting similarly
Quran speaks in Surah Bak CH 2 verse 29
that Allah made the Earth Summa the
heavens but unfortunately here abdah Ali
has translated Summa wrongly as
then in verse 29 of Sur Bak CH 2 he
translates Suma as then Allah created
the Earth and then the heaven then
there's a contradiction even here Suma
should be translated as moreover
simultaneously if if it's translated
simultaneously then it's not a
contradiction because the Big Bang
Theory tells us that the earth and the
heavens were created simultaneously no
wonder in the Quran the Quran says in
many places we created the Heaven and
the Earth in other places it says we
created the earth and the
heavens giving evidence to the ver of
the Quran of Surah Alia 21 verse number
30 it
says that do not believer see that the
Heaven and the Earth were join together
and we clove them
asand assalam alaykum I am gam Muhammad
I appreciate your explanation about the
bisexual reproduction in
animals and uh my question
is uh can
you support this uh change of sexcess in
animals and plants with the change of
nutrient and environment with the
chronic versions and also the production
of fruits without
fertilization brother has asked a very
good question he asked a question that
scientifically can you prove that there
are certain plants he mentioned and I I
can mention more few also bananas and
Har papaya the bisexual plants so if you
heard in my talk brother I made a
statement that even the bisexual plants
they have got distinct character itics
of male and female regarding a question
of fruits if you analyze the fruit is
the product of
reproduction is the end product of
reproduction of Superior
Plants of Superior Plants the stage
before fruit is the stage of flower the
flowers have got both male and female
stammen and
ules only after the Poland comes there
do you get fruit and then the fruit
gives off seed Etc the these are known
as parthenocarpic fruits even in these
there's distinct characteristic of male
and female and the Quran rightly says in
Sur 13 verse number three that we have
created fruits in pairs tools and tools
hope that answer the
[Applause]
question I'm fana mullah my question is
with regard to the evolution of homo
sapiens you have Charles Darwin ins son
giving an explanation that it's because
of the process of natural selection that
the human beings have evoled now this is
seems to be in contradiction with the
Islamic belief that we have we are the
children of Adam Alam now how can this
be
reconciled it's a very important
question no lecture of mine on this
topic of Quran modern science is
complete without this question I've
given this talk in various in Canada in
USA in UK in Saudi never is this topic
complete never is the question answer
complete without this important question
of theory of evolution Charles Darwin
sister p a question how can you
reconcile the Quran with Darwin's theory
of evolution sister I have not come
across any book which says fact of
evolution all the books say theory of
evolution there's no book I have come
across saying fact of evolution
if you read the book by Charles Darin
the Origin of Species it says that
Charles Darin went on an island by the
name of calat tropus on a ship named as
HMS Beagle and there he found birds
pecking at niches depending upon the
ecological niches they Peck the beaks
kept on becoming long and
short this observation was made in the
same species not in different species
Charles D drove wrote a letter to his
friend Thomas thpt in 1861 saying I do
not believe in natural selection the
word that you used I don't believe in
theory of evolution because I've got any
proof I only believe in it because it
helps me in classification of embryology
and morphology and rudimentary
organs Charles Davin himself said that
they were missing links he didn't agree
with
it he himself said that there were
missing links
therefore if I have to insult someone
that if you were present at dar's time
this Theory would have been proved right
trying to inate that he looks like an
namee it's a joke we
make the
reason that this theory in most parts of
the world it is taught as good as fact
you know why even I was in school I
learned about D Siri and even today they
taught you know what the reason is
Sister the reason is because
that if you analyze the church the
church was against SS previously and you
know the incidents that they sentenced
Galileo to death they sentenced Galileo
to death why because he said certain
statements in astronomy Etc which went
against the Bible so they sentenced him
to death for which the pope apologize
now so when Charles Darwin keep up with
a theory which goes against the
Bible they didn't they didn't want any
sufficient proof an enemy of my is my
friend so all the scientist most of them
they support the theory because it went
against the Bible not because it was
true they only supported it because it
went against the Bible all the stages we
have mentioned sister all the stages
Lucy there were four homones science
tells us today there's four homones
first is
Lucy along with his guide asopus which
died about 3 and a half million years
nice age then next came the homo sapiens
we died about 500,000 years ago then
came the near old man we died 100 to
40,000 years ago then came the fourth
stage the chrom magnon there is no link
at all between these
stages according to PP gra in 1971 who
held the chair of evolutionary studies
in Paris in the sh University he said it
is
absurd we cannot say who are ancestors
based on forces I can give you a list of
hundreds of scientists and Nobel Prize
winners who speak against D Theory
hundreds if you know of Sir
Albert Georgie who got the Nobel Prize
for
inventing for inventing the vitamin C he
wrote a book The Crazy Ape and man
against Davin
Siri again if you read s Fred H's Works
he wrote several works against Davin
theory if you know about
Albert this person wrote a new theory of
evolution against DAV Theory it's
Unthinkable we cannot think that we are
created from the Apes if you know of s
Frank Salisbury he was a
biologist he said it is illogical to
believe in darn theory if you know about
white meat so white meat he wrote a book
against darn he was also a biologist
several you can give a list of hundreds
today it is taught in the school
why I told you media is in their hand
otherwise there's no proof at all there
are certain proofs at lower levels and
amiba at lower species level amiba can
change to paramia Quran does not say
amiba cannot change to
paramia Quran does not say if they have
got proof can be possible it's not
against the Quran but there's no proof
at all people talk about molecular
biology Theory they talk about genetic
coding according to hanses Craig who
Authority in this field he he said it is
unimaginable again if you do that ratio
the probability of one DNA forming from
a to human being is again zero if I
start calculating I think you'll get
bored again you know the calculation I
told you for 1 14 molecule it is
somewhat similar from one DNA it is not
possible at all you know there's a
theory recently that homosexuality is
genetic and when I read in the times of
India I thought surely
the moment I attend the next lecture on
Sunday in irf I'll be asked this
question if homosexuality is genetic how
can Allah blame us Quran speaks against
homosexuality and I said that see this
is a theory wait till it get established
it's a theory don't comment on that
within the matter of span of this few
months it was proved to be
illogical and the person who propounded
this theory that homosexuality is
genetic himself was an
homosexual therefore I said I'm going to
give my talk on scientific facts not on
theories and assumption ding's theory
has not been proven we have not been
created from AE there are hundreds of
scientists speak against that and Quran
speaks against that also Quran says the
first man was Adam peace be upon Him
inshallah they'll Discover it 100 years
afterwards or maybe a thousand years
afterwards to that research showing that
human being have been created from one
pair again it's just a theory it
supports the quranic verse that human
beings have been created from one pair
male and female it's just a theory
therefore I don't quote that in my talk
inshallah it will be established 50
years afterwards or 100 years afterwards
then we'll know that Quran conciliates
with this part so far it's not
conflicting it's not conflicting
established science at all hope the
answer the
question the next question asalam
alaykum I'm Abdul samim I'm a student in
the
Quran it is stated
that the hearts of the unbelievers are
sealed but according to science it is
the brain that thinks and not the heart
your comment
please the brother POS the question that
the Quran says that the unbelievers
hearts have been sealed by Allah subhana
tala today science tells us it's the
brain that thinks and not the heart and
I do agree with him so is in the Quran
unscientific it says that the heart has
been sealed and I do agree Quran says
that in several places including Surah
bakar chapter 2 verse number seven that
Allah has sealed the hearts of the kafir
people it says that the seal has been
put on the
hearts if you know the Arabic word used
here is the Arabic word has got two
meanings one is heart and the other is
intelligence so if you translate
correctly the word says Allah has seed
the intelligence of the
unbelievers and it's scientifically
proven that intelligence has to be seen
not the organic heart but there are a
person who once put me the question
brother Zak I agree with you that means
heart as well as intelligence but one
verse in the Quran says the hearts are
behind the breast then what do you have
to give the answer for that and he was
quoting a verse of the Quran from Surah
Haj 22 verse number 46 which says that
the eyes are not blind it is the heart
which is in the breast which is blind so
Quran says the eyes are not blind it is
the heart which is within the breast
which is blind the science tells the I
see heart cannot see so isn't this verse
unscientific here the translation has to
be hard it can't be intelligence so I
tell him I agree with you the heart has
go two translations but the word used
for breast is s s s also has got two
meaning one is breast and the other is
Center you know how we have the head of
our institution we say s of of the
institution how we have sent if you have
been to Pakistan how in India we have
choke over there they have centers s so
and so s so and so in Pakistan Center so
and so s also means Center so the
correct translation is the eyes is not
which is blind it is the intelligence
which is within the center which is
blind same I started my talk by quoting
a verse of the Holy Quran from Surah
Taha chapter 20 verse number 25 28 which
says oh my Lord increase my breast for
me this was a Dua made by mam when he
was asked by Allah subhana wa ta'ala to
go and deliver the message to the people
he asked Allah oh my Lord increase my
breast for me see breast is not the
correct translation what's the breast go
to do with this message it means oh my
Lord increase my center for me
and make my task easy for
me and remove the impediment from my
speech so that they will understand me
as you know M Alam was a
stammerer and if you know whether
fortunately or unfortunately even I
happened to be a stammerer in childhood
I was a stammerer therefore at the
beginning of every talk and even the
beginning of this talk I said and I made
Dua to Allah subhana
tala oh my Lord increase my center for
me I'm asking help from Allah subhana wa
ta'ala increase my center and remove the
stuttering in my speech even today when
I don't speak on the stage I yet stutter
it's Allah who helps me out on the
stage oh my Lord increase my center for
me make my task easy for me and remove
the barrier from my speech and between
me and the audience so that they will
understand me therefore
scientifically scientifically if you
analyze the work of Surah Haj 22 vers
number 46 it says it is not the eyes
which are blind it is the intelligence
which is within the center is blind
because they are not blind unbelievers
can see saying they blind is
unscientific like the Quran says inah
Bak 2 vers number 18 it
says it says that death dumb the blind
they will not return to the
path the deaf the dumb the blind they
will not return the path it's not
talking about physical deaf people it's
talking about unbelievers who hearing
they cannot hear seeing the signs of
Allah they don't accept the Quran so
Quran is more scientific it says
correctly they can see the eyes are not
blind it is the intelligence within the
center which is
[Applause]
blind the next question from my brother
on my left
assalam alaikum to everybody who are
present here my name is khim sha I'm in
practicing interior designing in in
Bombay uh Quran have given all the
minute details of embryology apart from
a miracle or hazzat Adam alisam is it
not a contradictory that hazzat Isa
alisam is born without a father's pumps
what is the exact scientific
reasoning the brother POS a
question that how can you prove
scientifically the miracle of Jesus
peace be upon him that he was born
without a father without Mill
intervention brother as I said in my
talk a miracle is an unusual event for
which human beings cannot give an
explanation it's an unusual event which
is attributed to Supernatural power to
God
Almighty the Miracles which took place
in the past most of them do not give an
opportunity to analyze them today
because we can't go back in the past we
can't go back in the past there are few
Miracles which give us Antion to examine
them now all the prophets of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala who came before
Prophet muhammmad peace be upon him they
were only sent for their
people only for their people and the
message was for a limited time period
therefore even the miracle was for a
limited time period what Miracle did it
then satisfi those people those Miracle
just by saying that Jesus Christ was
born without any father will not satisfy
an unbeliever why he can't go back in
time and verify because all the
messengers that came before Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him they were
meant only for their time not for
eternity but Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he is the messenger of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala who's the last and
final messenger he was not only sent for
the Muslims or the Arabs he was sent for
the whole of humanity
and his message is still eternity
therefore the miracle that he has B the
Holy Quran can be analyzed even today
it's a miracle to Eternity Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him has done
hundreds of other Miracles which we
Muslims believe but he never emphasized
that we Muslims don't boast of that we
Muslims only boast of this because we
can't prove those Miracles
scientifically but this living Miracle
of prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
which was given to him by Allah subhana
wa taala can analyzed by us even today
so previous Miracles time does not allow
us to go back in time if you could go
back in time we could have analyzed how
was he born without a father but yet
brother I can yet give you a scientific
explanation I can yet give you today
science tells us there are certain
species which can be born without male
intervention and the best example is the
male bee the male bee is the egg which
has not been fertilized by male the
queen bee which lays eggs which doesn't
get fertilized by the male they are born
as male the female be is the eggs which
are fertilized by the male so there are
several animals today in this world who
are born without fertilization I do know
that this thing takes place in low
animals there's no proof in higher
animals who does it science cannot tell
us Allah's mother does it so when Allah
can make this
possible to happen in Isam where it is
described inah Al Imran 3 verse 45 to 47
it
says that behold the angel said to
Mary we give you you Glad Tidings of a
word from him his name shall be Christ
son of Mary
who will be held in honor in this world
and in the Hereafter and he will be
among the companies of those most
righteous those most
righteous the verse continues that he
will speak to the people in childhood
and in
maturity and will be among the people
those who are
righteous so may peace be upon us how
shall I have a son when no man has
touched me the answer is given
when Allah decreed the matter he just
said to it be and it
is I have given you a scientific
explanation when Allah can make it
possible in a male be it's very much
easy for Allah to make it
possible even in this inam for him Allah
subhana ta'ala to create a Jesus peace
be upon
[Music]
him when he decree the matter he just
said to it be and it is for him to
create a million people like that it's
just
easy it's a miracle I'm not telling you
Jesus Christ peace be upon was born like
that like the MBE I don't know I've
given you a scientific explanation when
it's possible there why can't Allah make
it in the higher animals the human
beings I hope to answer the question